[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend das
ganze Ausmaß der Verwüstung die das
Erdbeben in Marokko angerichtet hat ist
noch nicht absehbar aber es wird
gewaltig sein schon jetzt melden die
Behörden weit über 1.000 Tote das
Epizentrum lag im Atlasgebirge und 70 km
entfernt von Marrakesch die
Touristenstadt ist schwer betroffen das
Beben war aber auch bis an die Küste in
Städten wie Agadir Casablanca oder
Rabatt zu spüren
bilder einer Überwachungskamera es ist
kurz nach 23 Uhr als die Erde unter
ihren Füßen bebt
panik bricht aus
[Musik]
Anwohner und Touristen suchen Schutz auf
der Straße
genau hier ist unser Nachbar gestorben
da drüben ein kleines Mädchen und ihr
Bruder hat sich am Bein verletzt wir
sind auf die Straße gerannt sie war
voller Rauch viele Leute haben geweint
waren völlig schockiert jeder schaut auf
sein Handy was es passiert eine Bombe
sehr viel Unsicherheit
die Medina die Altstadt Marrakesch
Touristen Hotspot UNESCO Weltkulturerbe
gezeichnet vom Horror des Erdbebens
das Epizentrum der Stärke von rund 6,8
lag südwestlich von Marrakesch im dünn
besiedelten Atlasgebirge in rund 18 km
Tiefe
das Beben hat bislang 1305 Menschen
getötet und
1832 verletzt lokale Behörden sowie
sicherheits-
in entlegenere Gebiete sind die
Einsatzkräfte noch gar nicht
vorgedrungen
Zufahrtsstraßen zur bergdolfern sind
noch immer versperrt die Zahl der Toten
dürfte noch steigen so Unterstützung der
örtlichen Einsatzkräfte bereitet das
Technische Hilfswerk einen Einsatz in
Marokko vor andere sind schon unterwegs
seit dem Erdbeben in der letzten Nacht
die Klinge mein Handy ununterbrochen wir
sind jetzt dabei die Lage zu sondieren
Kollegen von uns sind auf dem Weg ins
Erdbebengebiet ich selbst werde mich
morgen auf dem Weg dorthin machen und
wir werden dann schauen wie die Bedarfe
sind aber es ist eigentlich jetzt schon
klar dass die Menschen das Nötigste
brauchen Nahrung
wasserkleidung Schutz Hygiene
für ihn kam die Hilfe rechtzeitig viele
andere warten noch immer auf Rettung die
Zeit läuft experten rechnen mit weiteren
Beben
unsere Partnerin an der Arend ist in
Marrakesch an was sind deine ersten
Eindrücke aus der Stadt auch jetzt am
Abend
der Platz auf dem wir hier stehen
jammert der ist voll wie eigentlich
jeden Abend mit dem großen Unterschied
dass heute Abend die Anspannung und auch
die Angst extrem groß sind viele fragen
sich wohin heute Nacht viele wollen
lieber im Freien bleiben aus Furcht vor
weiteren Nachbeben man muss dazu sagen
hier in der Altstadt in der Medina sind
diese traditionell gebauten Häuser
einsturzgefährdet viele sind auch
eingestürzt und wir befinden uns noch
nicht mal im Zentrum sozusagen das
Geschehens das Epizentrum liegt der 70
km von Marrakesch entfernt und dort sind
ganze Häuser zerstört und dort gibt es
leider auch die meisten Toten
hast du mich Informationen darüber ob da
auch schon hilfs und
Bergungsmaßnahmen ob der Retter
unterwegs sind oder weiß man dann auch
gar nichts aus diesen Atlasgebirge
Dörfern
also
vielleicht
Familien Verletzten wurden mehrere
blutspendezentren eingerichtet und es
steht tatsächlich zu befürchten dass die
Zahl der Opfer noch weiter steigt eben
deshalb weil diese Gebiete in den Bergen
so schwer zugänglich sind die Straßen
dorthin sind steil sind kurvig sind zum
Teil auch gar nicht asphaltiert und
teilweise ist auch das Strom und
Handynetz zusammengebrochen also es war
wirklich niemand auf diese Katastrophe
vorbereitet und es gab auch keinerlei
Vorwarnung
direkt aus Marrakesch danke
wenn sie den Menschen in Marokko helfen
wollen das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe nimmt Spenden an die
IBAN lautet de
65/100 400
600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Marokko Infos gibt es auch unter
spenden.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
Beileidsbekundungen und Hilfsangebote an
Marokko gibt es auch von Staats- und
Regierungschefs die zum G20-Gipfel in
Indien gereist sind das Treffen in
Neu-Delhi ist noch nicht zu Ende aber es
gibt schon eine gemeinsame
Abschlusserklärung um die wurde
wochenlang zwischen den Unterhändlern
gerungen vor allem um Formulierungen zum
ukrainekrieg das Russland diese
Abschlusserklärung nun als ausgewogen
lobt lässt tief blicken aber alle
betonen was für eine Volk ist doch sei
dass es überhaupt ein gemeinsames
Kommunität gibt als Bundeskanzler Scholz
in Berlin in den fliegerstieg war noch
nicht klar bis dazu kommt ultra hat den
ersten Gipfeltag für uns beobachtet
fast jeder Regierungschef bekommt seine
eigene Tanzeinlage für US-Präsident
beiden besonders schwungvoll dieser
Gipfel braucht harmonische Bilder für
eine Welt in der Krise
zur Begrüßung von Olaf Scholz sehen Sie
ich habe mich schön gemacht für meinen
Liebhaber der augenklappenkanzler will
selbst auf dem Gipfel seinen Charme
spielen lassen sein Flirt gilt der
Afrikanischen Union die offiziell der
g20-gruppe Beitritt ein großer
Fortschritt für den sich viele
eingesetzt haben wir in Deutschland auch
und deshalb ist das bemerkenswert dass
das in so kurzer Zeit nun gelungen ist
eine historische Umarmung von
gastgeber-modi und dem Präsidenten der
Afrikanischen Union die G20 fühlen sich
da wie eine Familie an das Motto des
Gipfels doch beim Thema Ukraine herrscht
Shiva vor dem Tagungsort der Gott der
Zerstörung
denn Russlands Außenminister hat nur
eine Mission zu verhindern dass der G20
Gipfel Russland wegen des
Angriffskrieges verurteilt deshalb
blockiert er zunächst eine gemeinsame
Abschlusserklärung China unterstützt ihn
der Russe bringt sich und den Gipfel ins
Straucheln Europa hält dagegen wichtig
ist dass wir die Grundsätze die
Grundprinzipien aufrecht erhalten und
diskutieren nämlich in der Ukraine z.B
die Frage das ist ein gerechten und
dauerhaften Frieden gibt die
Unverletzlichkeit von Grenzen die Gipfel
Regie inszeniert Indiens Regierungschef
Moody als großen Weltenlenker er liefert
und bringt einen Kompromiss zustande
in der Abschlusserklärung wird Russland
zwar nicht verurteilt aber die Gewalt in
der Ukraine die krisen-diplomatie bewegt
sich langsam durchs Chaos mehr war nicht
drin das spürt die deutsche Delegation
für mich
ist ein Zeichen dass das ein Erfolg ist
ja daran zu messen dass am Ende Russland
seinen Widerstand gegen eine solche
Beschluss aufgegeben hat
die Chinesen Spielen auf dem Gipfel
keine große Rolle sie schicken nur ihre
Nummer 2 Amerika nutzt das aus um sich
als Nummer eins zu präsentieren beiden
verkündet Milliardenhilfe für
Entwicklungsländer und einen
handelskorridor mit Indien
wir schaffen eine Zukunft die mehr
Chancen mehr Würde und mehr Wohlstand
den Menschen bringt
viel Harmonie verbreitet die Gipfel
Regie aber vom versprechen eine Familie
zu sein ist dieser Gipfel weit weg
und dann schalten wir noch zu unserem
Reporter in Neu Delhi ultra man hat den
Eindruck es wird für den Westen
schwieriger die Ergebnisse solcher
Gipfel treffen solcher G20 zu
beeinflussen
absolut ich glaube das war ein Gipfel
der nicht einfach war für den Westen
kann man an zwei Themen festmachen
einmal an der Ukraine da muss der Westen
doch feststellen dass immer mehr Länder
eben sagen das ist ein europäischer das
ist ein Krieg für den Westen und nicht
unser Krieg die Schwellenländer wollen
einfach andere Themen und sind müde
darüber zu diskutieren und deswegen ist
auch die etwas schwächliche
Schlusserklärung zustande gekommen weil
eine schärfere Verurteilung Russlands
gar nicht möglich war und das andere
große Thema ist Klima da sagen solche
Giganten wie Indien und China dass sie
gerade weiter auf Kohle setzen wollen
und sich eben nicht diesen strengen
klimastandards der Europäer zu eigen
machen da geht es auch er sagten manche
sogar er rückwärts und das sind zwei
Themen die dann doch den Europäern und
den besten sehr schwer macht auf diesen
Gipfel
du gehörst du den Auffälligkeiten dieses
Gipfels auch dass der chinesische
Präsidentin nicht angereist ist wie wird
das in neudele jetzt während dieser
Gipfel Tage interpretiert
also eigentlich ziemlich eindeutig Ski
hat damit klar gemacht dass er eben
nicht diese Bühne für so wichtig
erachtet er will sich diese Bühne auch
nicht teilen mit den Amerikanern sondern
er hat seine eigenen Organisationen er
hat zwei Bauerndörfer in China besucht
das war ein wichtiger als hier nach Deli
anzureisen allerdings hat man
festgestellt dass am Ende der Vertreter
von Ski hier mitgespielt hat eben diese
Abschlusserklärung nicht boykottiert hat
und das heißt zumindestens dass die
Chinesen geht 20 nicht ganz aufgeben
wollen aber sie machen sehr deutlich
dass es nicht ihr Format danke schön Ulf
für die Einschätzungen aus neuwilli
und jetzt geht's bei dir weiter Heinz
mit anderen Nachrichten in der Ukraine
laufen nach Aussage von Präsident
selenski die Vorbereitungen für den
zweiten Kriegswinter silent gesagt in
seiner täglichen videoansprache heute im
öffentlichen Sektor und in den Kommunen
müssen und jeder alles tun um der
Ukraine zu helfen den Winter zu
überstehen
silence Camping heute in Kiew den
japanischen Außenminister der der
Ukraine weitere Unterstützung zu sagte
lensky ging es auch um die Aufnahme von
Gesprächen über Sicherheitsgarantien für
die Ukraine
nordkorea hat den 75 jahrestag seiner
Staatsgründung mit einer nächtlichen
Militärparade begangen nach Berichten
der staatlich kontrollierten Medien habe
macht Tabak kim Jong und zum Jahrestag
Grußbotschaften von Chinas Präsident hi
und dem russischen Präsidenten Putin
erhalten das autoritär von Kim regierte
Land benutzt oft feiern oder Gedenktage
um Militärparaden abzuhalten und Stärke
zu demonstrieren
nach den mutmaßlichen Brandanschlägen
ist die Bahnstrecke zwischen Hamburg und
Berlin wieder freigegeben der Zugverkehr
normalisierte sich heute nachdem es
wegen der Beschädigungen zahlreiche
Zugausfälle und Umleitungen gegeben
hatte die Ermittler gehen von einem
politischen Motiv der Täter aus
in Venedig sind am Abend die
Filmfestspiele zu Ende gegangen mit der
Preisverleihung im diesjährigen
Wettbewerb der goldene Löwe für den
besten Film ging an pur senks des
griechischen Regisseurs
die Filmfestspiele Venedig zählen zu den
bedeutendsten der Welt im diesjährigen
Wettbewerb hatten 23 Werke um die Preise
konkurriert
die Invictus Games wurden heute eröffnet
erstmals in Deutschland Invictus heißt
ja auf Lateinisch so viel wie unbesiegt
unbezwungen Soldatinnen und Soldaten die
schwere Verwundungen und Traumata
erlitten haben und die sich auch über
den Sport zurück ins Leben kämpfen als
kriegsversehrte nicht unsichtbar zu sein
sondern öffentlich aufzutreten Kraft zu
zeigen darum geht es mehr als 500
Teilnehmer treten in verschiedenen
Sportdisziplinen gegeneinander an dass
diese Sportfest so prominent geworden
ist liegt natürlich an ihrem Gründer und
Schirmherrn Prinz Harry von der
Eröffnung in Düsseldorf berichtet Thomas
[Applaus]
die große Düsseldorfer Arena komplett
verdunkelt um die Lightshow noch mehr zu
betonen und schon bei der Vorstellung
der Teams fließen Tränen im Publikum
aber auch bei jeder Mannschaft hier das
deutsche Team die die hier auf der Bühne
stehen haben sich zurückgekämpft ins
Leben trotz schwerster körperlicher oder
seelischer Verletzungen sowie
Bogenschütze Jens Niemeyer der als
Soldaten Afghanistan war und danach zehn
Jahre lang allein mit einer
posttraumatischen Belastungsstörung
kämpfte
Familie oder die Kinder und die Frauen
viel gelitten in der Zeit einfach schon
sehr forscht mir war es auch teilweise
egal was die Familie macht ich habe mein
Ding versucht durchzuziehen eine
jahrelange Therapie und der gemeinsame
Sport mit anderen denen es ähnlich gegen
halfen Niemeyer wieder in die Spur
ich freue mich eigentlich mit dem Team
so viele wir Momente als möglich zu
haben und das ist auch etwas was er halt
niemand nehmen kann und auch keine
Medaille kann das dir irgendwie geben es
ist einfach ja unbeschreiblich das
Gefühl um solche Gefühle geht es ihm
Prinz Harry der du auf Sex die Spiele
seine Idee eine wahre
Herzensangelegenheit
guten Abend
zusammen und hältst wie kommen Sünden
Invictus Games 203 hier in Düsseldorf
sind nicht über Medaillen oder
Bestleistungen zu bewerten es dreht sich
alles darum Hindernisse und
Einschränkungen zu überwinden
insbesondere die die man sich selbst
auferlegt hat
der Prinz verfolgt die Spiele die ganze
Woche über in Düsseldorf gleiches Prinz
Harry gemeinsam mit
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
auch live zu Gast im Aktuellen
Sportstudio im ZDF Sendezentrum in Mainz
wurde er vor wenigen Minuten empfangen
und ein Ergebnis vom Fußball von heute
Abend zum Start in die EM-Saison hatte
die deutsche Nationalmannschaft am Abend
in Wolfsburg das Team Japans zu Gast und
Deutschland hat verloren eins zu vier
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 2 22 25 28
42 88 Superzahl 5 und weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im zdf-text auf Seite 556 und noch
die Wetteraussichten für morgen es
bleibt weiterhin bei viel Sonnenschein
und mit 24 bis 33 Grad
überdurchschnittlich heißt auch in den
nächsten Tagen bleibt die Hitze erst
einmal noch ab Dienstag kommt die
Abkühlung und es wird gewittrig
das war's von uns gleich also das
aktuelle sportstudio und da können wir
dann sehen die Prinz Harry und
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius in
der Torwand gegeneinander antreten bis
morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]